shiva is a young kurdish woman fighting  against is in northern iraq  i was planning to go there to meet her  but in the end i wasn't able to  for safety reasons  shiva says islamist ideology is one of  the reasons she left her native iran to  join the kurdish militia known as the  peshmerga  shiva sent me videos from the front  i'm just waiting for the peshmerga woman  to get back to their military camp and  then they want to  get in touch with us via skype and i  hope the connection will be good enough  to get an insight on their experience on  the front line  hello  both  are no match for the highly  sophisticated weaponry used by iss  shiva says of course she'd rather live  in peace but to get there she feels for  now she has to keep fighting  she says her message to young people  everywhere is to avoid extremism of any  kind  especially when it comes to religion  you